-I want to ask about this.
Because, um,
do you have a scuba background?
Because you went to an opening
of an aquarium in Missouri?
-Yes. Yeah, Johnny Morris opened
this beautiful wildlife museum.
Johhny Morris is the founder
of Bass Pro Shop.
-Uh-huh.
-And all of a sudden,
George Bush was there,
Jimmy Carter.
They´re like, "oh, you want to
get in the shark tank?"
I´m like, "no, I don´t want to
get in the shark tank."
They´re like, "no, no, no,
it would be really cool.
Get in the shark tank with the
stingrays and everything else."
Next thing you know, I´m diving
in this tank.
I mean, I literally just showed
up to say hello.
-Uh-huh.
-To show my support
for the opening of the museum.
-And there you are.
That´s, I guess,
a little stingray, right?
-Yeah.
-Although, I don´t mean
to say little. If I saw that,
I´d be terrified.
-That´s how that guy
Steve Irwin died.
-Yeah.
-He got stabbed by a stingray.
-I don´t think in, like,
an aquarium, though.
[ Laughter ]
-You know what?
I don´t think they´re, like,
really trainable animals,
either.
You know, like, "hey, this one´s
not a stinger."
That´s a stinger right there,
that thing on the back.
Yeah, that´s the little thing
that --
-No, I think they have to go
through a really --
a long training before they let
them in the aquarium.
-Well, anyway, I went there.
We´re trying to persuade
these guys to do
this Wahlburger partnership,
open restaurants in
these Bass Pro Shops.
´cause people go there for,
like, six hours,
and they´re like, "yeah, we´re
really into the idea."
But now we´re in a tank, and we
still don´t have a Wahlburgers
in a Bass Pro Shop.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, so this was -- you saw this
as a business opportunity,
and it totally backfired.
-You see what I do
to support my brand? Uh, yeah.
And didn´t work out quite
the way I had hoped, so...
-And was it -- did it increase
the pressure to have
two ex-presidents watch you get
into a scuba tank?
-Oh, they´re all sitting there
just having
hors d´oeuvres and cocktails
and looking...
Basically paying no attention
to me whatsoever --
-Well, I guess that´s
the thing is --
-And you can´t really see out.
-Yeah.
-You know? And I´m like, "I´ve
got to go somewhere else
the same day."
-Yeah.
-And, like, people
just kind of left me.
There was one other diver.
And they were just, like,
doing these signals.
-[ Laughs ]
-And I´m like, "I don´t know
scuba signals."
-Also, you can barely
tell it´s you.
So it´s not that exciting to
watch if someone´s like,
"ladies and gentlemen,
Mark Wahlberg."
You´d be like,
"that could be anybody."
-Exactly.
-You do get a -- which is
very surprising to me, because
you´ve been doing this so long
and you´re so recognizable.
But you do get mistaken for one
actor more than other actors.
-Yes.
-You want to tell us who it is?
-My fellow Bostonian Matt Damon.
-Yeah.
-And by the way, your clip about
all the Boston movies...
-Oh...
-Was one of the funniest things
I´ve ever seen.
-[ Laughs ] Thank you.
-Much better Boston accent than
most of the people in Boston,
by the way,
so thank you for that.
-Yes, I don´t think
I´m top tier, but I do think
I´m better than bottom.
-No, it´s -- it´s pretty high.
-Yeah.
-It´s pretty high.
So anyway, yeah, he gets
recognized, you know, for me
and I get recognized for him.
But I never tell people.
I never correct anybody.
Somebody comes up and says,
"hey, I loved you
in ´The Bourne.´"
I´m like, "thank you. I got
another one coming out soon."
And I just keep going.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It´s like, I start explaining --
-Yeah.
-I didn´t want to apologize.
-They think I´m offended.
I´m not offended at all.
Not a problem,
thank you very much.
-[ Laughs ]
-I´ll see you later.
-You shot some of this movie,
"Daddy´s Home 2," in Boston.
-Yes.
-Is it exciting for you
to shoot in Boston?
-No.
-Okay.
-Well, like, random people
showing up unannounced
and uninvited. No.
-Oh, right,
´cause you have such...
-But every -- yeah, I have
a long history there.
You know, it´s nice to be able
to see my mom and stuff.
But, you know, like, everybody´s
like, "oh, I love Boston!"
Everybody who, like, went to
school to Boston
or spent a little time,
spent the summer in Nantucket
or on the cape, they love it.
You know, if you´ve been there,
you know, there´s a reason why
you wanna -- I mean,
I love going back. And I
appreciate that I can go back.
But I have people from my past,
some of them kind of sketchy
that´ll show up unannounced.
Like, my friends were, like,
plotting to steal
camera equipment before
on "The Perfect Storm."
And they were like,
"wow,
that thing looks expensive."
I´m like, "yeah, it´s like
$250,000."
They´re like, "oh, let´s put it
in the trunk."
[ Laughter ]
I´m like, "who are you going to
"sell a Panovision camera to?
You´re going to sell it to
"George at the store
for 500 bucks
"and a free -- free pizza? He´s
not gonna be able to use it.
They´re gonna --
they´re gonna catch you."
-I didn´t think of it that way.
That makes a lot of sense.
Hey, it´s always great to see
you. Congrats on the film.
It´s a pleasure.
-Thanks for having me.